prohibition is far more dangerous and
it's negative consequences are far more
dangerous than any consumption of
marijuana itself
to my fellow Republican moms I would
have this to say for too long we have
allowed the government to parent or
children and when we think about the
things that are most important to our
kids whether it's our crumbling public
schools or unsafe roads that are riddled
with potholes soldiers that are getting
killed right now in Iraq because they
lack the proper support and their
armored vehicles we need to know that it
is this failed marijuana prohibition
experiment that is taking billions of
dollars away from those other far more
important priorities every year
we need to have priority based budgeting
and based on science and based on public
policy and based on our law enforcement
priorities marijuana prohibition doesn't
make sense having worked in an inner
city jail and seeing that the vast
majority of people there are there
because of drug-related offenses we need
to reprioritize we need to take another
look and say is jail the best place for
these people while it may be true that
the eight hundred and fifty thousand
Americans who are put into our criminal
justice system because of marijuana use
may not end up in our prisons the fact
remains that those people whether they
receive a citation or a 20-year prison
sentence are taking our focus away from
fighting far more serious drug epidemics
including prescription drugs as a mother
my biggest concern is not that my kids
will smoke a joint at 16 but they will
that they will find oxycontin or vicodin
and some parents medicine cabinet
my relationship with my children is all
about honesty and self-respect I hope my
children never abused their bodies and
that they treat themselves with the
respect that they deserve and this much
is true prohibition of marijuana will
not stop my children from using it and
my primary concern is not that they
reach a certain age when they start
using drugs but that whenever they
decide to use drugs whether it be
caffeine or alcohol or cigarettes
marijuana or whatever else that they
know that they can come to me and that
they continue to treat themselves with
respect and honesty that they deserve I
don't want police officers knocking on
my door telling me how to parent it
doesn't work it doesn't stop a single
kid in this country from trying illegal
drugs
well in this two-party system that we
have being a libertarian makes it much
more difficult to have a venue or a
vehicle for the policy changes you
support and I also feel a real loyalty
to the party that I grew up in our
political ideology our political party
is such an important part of who we are
and when I think about my children's
future I want them to have the most
opportunity the most freedom and the
best understanding of individual rights
and responsibilities and if I can do my
part to get my political party to come
back to its roots then I believe I've
provided the best opportunity for my
children is the Republican Party perfect
far from it but out of the options that
we've got today it's the best thing I
think I've got going for my family
right now we face a crisis of epic
proportions when it comes to our economy
and inflation that we are going to see
over the next several years so my focus
is on changing current policies that
needlessly or unproductively drain our
public coffers at a time when we need
more money than ever to fight for our
other priorities so my focus is on
marijuana and I think we should have a
conversation about heroin or meth but
that's for another day right now we have
an opportunity to end a failed seven
decade experiment of prohibition against
marijuana and we should do it because
it's the right thing to do it's the
moral thing to do and it's ultimately
the best thing to do for our children
we need to treat drug addiction as an
addiction as a health problem and having
worked in a jail and seeing so many
addicts behind bars we know or I know
from that personal experience that
putting these people behind bars doesn't
do anything to help them end their
addictions our stigma in this country
with marijuana use is far out of touch
with reality shouldn't we allow or
encourage people like Michael Phelps or
linebackers in the NFL who are suffering
injuries or even the stress of such a
rigorous lifestyle shouldn't we
encourage them to use organic substances
that are far less harmful than alcohol
or any sort of pharmaceutical
alternative we should be encouraging
that and we should end the stigma and
that being said I'm often tagged as this
pothead and I think my role in all of
this is to say look this isn't about pot
to me I don't care about pot if I never
imbibe any marijuana in any form again I
will live a happy and fulfilled life
this is about my kids this is about the
priorities that we should have a [ __ ] as
a country and this is about teaching our
government to admit when it's made a
mistake and moving on